so I've been pumped to talk to this guy
because ever since I found out he
launched a food blog the greatest thing
ever like my two loves are sports and
food I think many people feel the same
way rich Cho is the general manager of
the Charlotte Hornets and he has
launched a food ball a blog here big
time bites calm rich before we get into
that who wins one-on-one Michael with
one leg or Lavar ball for sure MJ would
you be allowed to answer differently if
you felt differently I would never feel
differently anyway here MJ if Michael
said publicly I could beat someone
one-on-one with no arms and no legs
you're picking Michael or that person
I'm picking MJ all right let's talk
about your website Big Time bites calm
this is odd I don't know that Gregg
Popovich is like an uber driver in the
offseason you have a little bit of a
side hustle going on how did this all
start you know I've always loved pet
loves food and when I'm always on the
you know I'm on the road a lot whether
it's a big city like New York or San
Fran or a small city like a college city
like Lexington or Lawrence Kansas and
just always looking for good food and
I'll ask around before I go to those
cities Hayes you know a good place in
Lawrence or Davidson and and try and get
recommendations and then you know you
just try and look for good food and then
I get asked a ton myself and just having
been to a lot of places I give out a lot
of recommendations and then I wind up
writing those down in my notepad and I
thought a couple years ago I thought you
know what I'd like to create a food fly
so I can kind of put all this together
and kind of share my love for food and
have people share share it among
themselves as well so like for example
you drafted Malik monk out of Kentucky
when you're going to Scout Malik bunk
and you're making a phone call let's say
in advance of John Calipari are you
asking two questions
tell me about monk and tell me where to
eat yeah kind of yeah you know which one
comes from which one comes first though
or the player of course but coach Cal
got his favorites he even has dishes
named after him at certain restaurants
so he'll know where the good spots are
and a lot of the assistant coaches they
know where the spots are too at the
Coach Cal restaurant you only get an
appetizer you don't get any other meals
just one and done right away you don't
get anything else of course talking with
rest show the general manager of the
Charlotte Hornets Evan Cohen Mike bad
chicken for Dan Patrick Dan Patrick show
rich has a blog a big-time bites calm
did you have to ask Michael Jordan's
permission to do this you know MJ knows
I'm a big eater if you know he's ready
to comment before that I have a hollow
leg so he's aware and you know he knows
I love to eat and he knows my affinity
for food this was he worried at all that
it would take time away from your GM job
now you know that the thing is I don't
sleep too much I sleep like four hours a
night and always really have since law
school and I've got you know I don't
have a lot of vices really like I don't
go work out two hours a day like some
people I don't do things like other
people you know I've got it's really my
work and then I've got some a you know
food vise and then it's my kids so that
that's about it that's all I do really
what's more enjoyable for you analyzing
a player or analyzing a meal well
definitely the job comes first and now
the great thing about this job is it's
all basketball related and the funnest
part about my job is just combining my
analytical background you know
engineering degree in law degree with
the the basketball part so it's it's all
fun for me rich who pays for more of
these meals that you that you write
about you or Michael I'm paying for them
but if you're if you're on you're
telling me if you're on the road with
the Hornets and you go to dinner you
have some sort of per diem don't you I
mean it did Michael kind of paying for
this blog yeah yeah well no and
Monteverde I'm sure everybody in the
that travel is in the NBA is on a per
diem so in other words yeah the courses
are paying for it so I look at this
thing and it's amazing big-time fights
calm how you analyze this how you
actually break down each meal tell
everybody how you do that both in terms
of the taste as well as the pricing yeah
so first of all to put in a there's a
sports LAN to the food blog so like all
my reviews are called scouting reports
and then visitors can put in the
scouting report too so it's kind of a
hybrid of my reviews Plus almost like a
Yelp type environment so I don't think
this model is out there anywhere but you
put in your you put in a picture and
then you put in a rating and we've got
five different raises rotation starter
all-star franchise and Hall of Fame so
like a Hall of Fame dish is the best of
the best it's equivalent to like a
player the best of the best and then I
also have something in there which says
okay this is a dish that should be on
your bucket list before you die so so
you rate that you rate the dish you put
in the information for where the
restaurant is you put in the cuisine
we've got a bunch of different flags in
there so if it's a Spanish dish you put
in the Spanish flag you put in your
scatter report you put in we've got a
rubric for the price and then you also
put in whether it's open breakfast lunch
dinner or late night and then you save
your report and then it goes on to our
website outside of Charlotte best envy
a city for a meal whoo you know I love
there's so many different good food
cities but once they do I really love
it's Boston they've got a lot of great
soups and seafood out there
Ellie's got a lot of great cities a lot
of great food but if I had to pick one
and probably Boston with the lobster
rolls up there and the seafood now where
are you lobster rolls are so interesting
because I get into this debate with
people all the time are you do you like
the Mayo we lobster roll like the
buttery one the hot of the cold where
are you on the lobster roll I like the
hot yeah me too
because the flavor of lobster needs to
be there right don't you think the male
one kind of takes it away a little bit
yeah you know you either one is probably
it looks probably not good for the
calorie count but personally I like the
hot better and you're right the male
does take away from it talk with rich Oh
general manager of the Charlotte Hornets
they do have a basketball team but it's
not as interesting as Big Time bites
comm I have to be honest with you
if you could switch careers right now
with one person would you switch with
Bob Meyers the general manager of the
Warriors or Guy Fieri I could switch
curry well I won't be switching careers
with Bob but but if I had a different
life yeah it probably something of food
actually I'm big on tennis too so I
probably trying to do something tennis
related but you wouldn't want to be guys
Yeti I mean diner isn't diners drive-ins
and dives kind of what you're doing in
more of an online base of it yeah I know
that that'd be a good kick to you've got
a great gig same with Andrew Zimmerman
that going around everywhere
eating eating odd stuff I I'd be into
that too what's the end game is it to
get a show on the Food Network
no this is really this is a kind of just
a fun thing that that hoping to share my
love for food with everybody and the end
game you know if we were able to ever
make some money out of it I'd want to
probably donate it somewhere um
you know I was born in Burma and one
thing I want to do down the road is is
be able to make enough money to help
some people in Burma there is an let's
finish with this rich there is an irony
about a man who grew up in Burma who
came to the United States who didn't
have much money wasn't eating a lot now
a successful general manager and doing a
food blog I mean there is sign a kind of
an amazing story tale or fairy tale to
this No
well yeah yeah I guess there is I guess
there is some irony in that but well
probably my favorite cuisine in the
world is Burmese food which is one I
don't know what that is like I wouldn't
know what that was it was in front of me
right now yeah it's a it's a cross
between Thai Chinese and Indian it's
probably the best way I can explain it
a Chinese and that sounds good to me I
mean it's a little it's a little Indian
food with a little spice in there that's
that's tremendous yeah tremendous
well listen I'm excited about this big
time bites calm I may even do a review I
got to be honest that's the coolest
things I could do a review I don't know
if I want to review the Dwight Howard
trade as much but I would like to review
this big-time bites calm rich show who
gets his meals paid for by Michael
Jordan whether he's acknowledging that
or not an MJ would beat we learned from
him that MJ would beat someone with no
arms and no legs in one-on-one that
you'd still pick MJ thank you rich
there's a rich oh okay
show the general manager of the
Charlotte Hornets Big Time bites dot-com
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience